y
i
'cuba libre'
las emoción no les voy a invitar una
ronda de jong con cocacola tampoco vamos
a hablar de un régimen político y menos
les voy a recitar las capacidades
extraordinarias de las personas con
discapacidad
ni que fuera de las heroínas de marvel
de lo que tengo ganas es de contarles la
catarsis esta metamorfosis cerebral que
experimenta en cuba'
con algo de dinero grado de vista va a
los destinos pendientes de mi bucket
list cuando algo hizo que me decidiera a
ir a cuba digo su complejidad política
siempre me había llamado la atención
pero un país tan particular no era
probablemente la opción más sencilla
para que yo salga por primera vez en mi
silla de ruedas
esa hermosa sensación que siento cada
vez que voy a descubrir un lugar nuevo
se estaba mezclando con miedo el cual
sentía cada vez que tenía que averiguar
si el hospedaje en donde iba a llegar
tenía la no tenía muchas escaleras o si
la ciudad tenía el servicio de
transporte lo suficientemente accesible
pero cruce los dedos y empecé a armar la
maleta mientras veía que la silla no
esté con las llantas bajas
llegó el día de partida atrasada para
variar conducía algo rápido al
aeropuerto cuando vi que había un
operativo de los agentes de tránsito y
me detiene dije y ahora menos puntos de
la licencia multada chau viaje pero no
era un operativo de los de control de
armas de seguridad algo así así que
empecé a buscar mis documentos entre los
million cosas de mi bolso
cuando el agente se acerca y al ver la
silla de ruedas se pone nervioso
tartamudea y me dice no tranquila usted
siga nomás
bueno
es en serio bien podría llevar un
cadáver en la cajuela o
un arma sin el permiso correspondiente
de drogas pero al parecer la silla de
ruedas dista de la poli aparentemente
una persona en silla de ruedas no puede
ser delincuente o cometer alguna
infracción
y en la sala de embarque luego de
burlarme internamente de todos los que
si tienen que hacer fila ni a quien
rebase en pocos minutos
a ver desde esos privilegios que
disfruta un montón
me empezaron a temblar las piernas las
manos hasta las orejas crema porque o
sea era mi primera vez y la primera vez
unos se ponen nerviosos yo no
cuatro horas después llegó a mi destino
y al salir del avión encuentro la silla
medio rota y sin la persona de la
aerolínea que está ahí normalmente para
ayudarme qué onda usualmente los varios
puestos son mi lugar disney son tan
perfectos tan accesibles tanta
amabilidad para quisiera vivir ahí
pero este no era el caso me tocó empujar
la silla sudando y aún no por ahora con
la maleta encima ante la mirada cual
museo que nunca falta ni de los adultos
ni de las bendiciones
hasta que uno de los pasajeros me ayudó
y me llevó a donde mi anfitrión me
esperaba con mi amiga de aventura que
había llegado a unos minutos antes de
escocia
llegué al casco antiguo de la habana
donde una señora de los más dulces nos
recibió con una sopita buenas ya lo que
ya me despido para dormir me dice en voz
bajita eres una heroína
que no que no soy una heroína ya
quisiera yo sé como tony star
pero le sangre mientras le torcía los
ojos por dentro
al día siguiente heroína villana salimos
de recorrer el centro de la habana
rompiendo mi tradición de tener todo
organizado y llevar las riendas del
viaje cruzaba los dedos para que mi
amiga vaya a lugares que también me
interese a la final dependía de ella y
sentía que hasta pobres y próxima
reciprocidad tenía que decir sí claro
perfecto me encanta vamos
si el cielo existe en este viaje mi
amiga se lo ganó porque además de
empujar constantemente la silla batalla
con calles super angostas invadía la
calle esquivaba una que otra visita -que
si pensándolo bien ella podría ser una
heroína
fue ahí donde mi cerebro empezó a ser
cortocircuito porque osea no habían
rampas pero jamás faltó alguien que me
ayude y no querían propinas y es lo que
creen no entendía cómo ahí sentía más
accesibilidad que mi propia ciudad en
donde no faltan las rampas claro algunas
de ellas están mal ubicadas que no
sirven o con los conductores que agarran
coche en el paso
pero la diferencia estaba en algo
llamado empatía no lastima no admiración
simplemente empatía que es nada más
percibir el sentir del otro y tomar una
acción ponerse en los zapatos de otra
persona
días después fuimos latinidad recogemos
sus exageradamente empedradas calles
cuando un joven se nos acercó y nos dijo
y nos ofreció en un tour a una cascada y
un ingenio azucarero le expliqué que no
puedo caminar mucho casi nada y que no
soy el profesor de kissimmee silla de
ruedas no vuela
y me dijo tranquila de que llega llega
música para mis oídos empezamos el viaje
que nos tomó una hora más de lo normal
en un caballo más pequeño de lo normal
hasta donde éste pudo acceder llegamos
ahí y pequeña noticia nos dicen que hay
que caminar 15 minutos por un camino con
unas cuantas piedrecitas
esos 15 minutos se hicieron más de una
hora realmente difícil
siguen y se como pero valió muchísimo la
pena hermosísimo el lugar
y claro todo lo bueno llega a su fin yo
sufría internamente porque o sea todo lo
que padecía
para llegar había que hacerlo otra vez
avanzábamos tan lento ya de regreso
hasta que el joven más bien me cargó y
me llevo en su espalda y así pues qué
diferencia llegamos en 15-20 minutos
yo sé perdón ahí es cuando me encanta
ese tamaño económico o manualista como
me dice
quise gritar in your face a la monja
para que mi estatura fue un cero
inconveniente para que no estudie en su
prestigiosa escuela oa la profe del
conservatorio que no me aceptó por mi
supuesta debilidad mientras de ellas me
impusieron sus barreras
este joven quitó obstáculos que en
realidad existían diablos vieron esas
piedras
y claro no puede faltar la para este
curso que viaje no tiene alguna aventura
y romántica
me estaba tomando mi segundo tercero
bueno me estaba tomando un mojito
cuando conocí a un chico que le dio otro
punto este lugar él empezó por contarme
sus fetiches por mi estatura como sí lo
hacen entender
tengo tintos
ni tampoco se fue al extremo de tratarme
de usted y felicitarme por conocer otro
país a pesar de tener una discapacidad
él hizo el mix perfecto bailo como un
dios de la salsa conmigo y horas después
se presta empujar la silla el como me ha
pasado con muy pocas personas no jugó
hacer la enfermera que tiene que
cuidarme ni tomo el rol de mamá que
tiene que protegerme o prohibir me de lo
que puedo o no puedo hacer en pocas él
no decidió por mí nada más dejó que las
cosas fluyeron y vaya que fluyeron
y en el último día justo antes de
regresar fuimos a un festival de música
con un par de amigas que conocimos allá
todo iba bien hasta que me dijeron que
para personas con discapacidad hay una
zona exclusiva en donde solo yo y una
persona más podríamos estar ojo en
algunos eventos acá maneja en el mismo
protocolo les digo la verdad apesta
podrán decir que estoy loca pero estando
en un lugar nuevo con buena música
buenos amigos lo último que a cualquier
joven de mi edad le preocupa es que la
salida de emergencia esté cerca y yo no
soy la excepción estoy consciente de que
me pueden aplastar de que puedo tener un
accidente de que necesito tal vez más
ayuda a que otras personas pero adivinen
que eso no pasa solo un concierto y
tampoco me pase sólo a mí es que si
vivimos la vida todos o así deberíamos
arriesgándonos por eso que nos hace
libres viviendo la vida con todo y miedo
improvisando y ya sin drama
como todo viaje cuba me transformó pero
sobre todo cuba llevo a mi cerebro a una
metamorfosis que yo no pedí pero que me
liberó descubrí que la paz desea de
tener una discapacidad es tener que
convencer constantemente al texto de que
si puedo de que soy más de lo que ven de
que si hay privilegios que agradezco y
otros que me incomoda de que contratar
el 4 por ciento de personas con
discapacidad por obligación premia la
existencia de una minoría y eso es todo
menos inclusión todos somos buenos para
algo si soy diferente y quien no lo es
estoy convencida de que la clave para
que una sociedad sea inclusivo en verdad
es la empatía empatía no sobreprotección
bajemos de por un poquito el
paternalismo digo sé que lo hacen de
buenas gentes pero nada más y es más
práctico déjenos decidir a nosotros lo
que podemos o no podemos hacer si
necesitamos o no necesitamos ayuda si
necesitamos de ayuda tranquilo se las
vamos a pedir
es más me da una manita al bajas las
gradas de la salida porfa gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]